on en accueille tro ce soir il y a
Philippe Grégoire bonsoir Philippe
bonsoir merci d'être là agriculteur en
Méloir vous entre le covid la guerre en
Ukraine
l'inflation c'est quoi votre situation
comment on peut s'en sortir alors la
situation du monde agricole pour la
comprendre faut bien penser qu'il y a
8020 il y a 20 % des agriculteurs qui
sont s'en sortte bien qui sont au-dessus
de 1766 € brut le SMIC brut c'est-à-dire
globalement certains grands céréaliers
et la viticulture les grand vigobes et
il y en a 80 % qui sont dans les chou
donc 42 % en dessous le RSA pourquoi ce
que faut que les téléspectateurs il
sachent c'est que dans les 80 % pour la
grande majorité lorsqu'on fait des
productions on n pas notre carnet de
facture c'est pas nous qui faisons la
facture c'est l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui appartient à la
FNSEA que j'appelle maintenant la France
nouvelle sans exploitant agricole donc
dans ces 80 % vous faites des canards
des poulets des cochons des lapins vous
êtes obligé de passer soit par un
abattoir soit par une laitterie un outil
de transformation et c'est l'outil de
transformation qu' a la main et qui fait
la facturation et après ce qu' a tué le
monde agricole bien entendu c'est la
libre circulation des biens des hommes
des marchandises et des capitaux puisque
ces oligopoles du syndicat sont sur tous
les continents alors quand on vous dit
c'est de la démagogie on veut pas
importer de la viande du Brésil la
viande du Brésil est nourrie par la
société du groupe ou er Rousseau quand
on dit la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est un faux
débat ils sont installés en
Nouvelle-Zélande ils ont une compagnie
aérienne qui vend du vin et ils vendent
des aliments là-bas du bétail le groupe
avril donc si vous voulez faut arrêter
de prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
on peut pas jouer les multinationales à
travers le monde mettre ses billes à
travers le monde et se faire porter en
victime dire oh là là là là on est
contre les importations alors que c'est
eux qui les ont organisé sur un cadit de
100 € en supermarché il ne revient vient
euh à l'agric 6,50 €50 tout à fait vous
rendez compte ou pas alors j'aimerais
juste on je vouis vous poser une
question j'ai j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
je dis euh voilà je dis aussi qu' a les
normes européennes elles sont pas les
mêmes pour tout le monde et que vous
vous êtes étranglais est-ce que vous
pouvez me le confirmer ça oui mais si
vous voulez c'est pas les normes la la
base c'est qu'on a perdu notre facture
on est tenu par nos acheteurs même si
vous avez les mêmes normes si vous
restez en Europe l'Allemagne c'est
équivalent voire supérieur la Suède le
danemarque la Hollande Hollande
nettement supérieur à nous certes le sud
il y a moins de normes mais si vous vous
restez que parler des normes c'est que
vous voulez contourner le débat si vous
parlez du GNR du gasoile non routier
c'est une manœuvre des oligopoles pour
contourner le débat il y a des
agriculteurs qui utilisent pas de gasoil
qui sont avec des horsol qui utilisent
pas de gasoil ils sont en faillite le
vrai problème c'est le prix de nos
produits où on est tenu par des
oligopoles et ça je peux vous en parler
il y a quelques acteurs qui sont bien
connus Bigard deux hollandais sur lesvau
vous êtes au C courant que les veau il y
en a qui sont rendus à les tuer dans les
exploitations parce qu'un veau ça coûte
plus cher de le faire boire que de le
nourrir vous êtes au courant de ça il y
a deux hollandais qui ont la main sur le
marché du veau en Europe en Europe des
oligopoles et après vous dites le
problème c'est le GNR le problème c'est
l' nororme le problème c'est un écolo
non mais attendez un écolo il paye pas
les produits agricoles aux agriculteur
moi je vends pas mes produits aux écolos
je le vends à l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui tient
pay oui donc et plus vous êtes
industrialisé plus vous faites du horsol
plus vous faites des gros élevages plus
vous êtes attachés parce que plus vous
avez d'emprunt et pour terminer ce que
je vais vouler vous dire c'est que la
boucle elle est bouclée par le
gouvernement ces projets là il ont été
mis en place par tous les gouvernements
successifs la banque publique
d'investissement le Crédit Agricole KKR
krber kravit Roberts qui travaille avec
Black Rock et la FNSEA et la FNSEA voilà
le schéma on est dans une
financiarisation de l'économie qui fait
qu'un paysan il a plus rien entre les
mains sauf s'il vaend au détail on est
bien d'accord sauf les petits circuits
courts et les ventes au détail mais ça
c'est 3 milliards sur 76 milliards
d'euros de la ferme France donc les
circuits courts c'est très bien mais
c'est pinots alors j'ai vu Sandrine
Rousseau qui a tweeté aujourd'hui je
sais pas si vous avez vu ce que font les
agriculteurs depuis 2 jours explosion
dans un bâtiment une personne tué rail
dégradé est inadmissible et le silence
du gouvernement est absolument
incroyable
elle a supprimer derrière euh g vous en
pensz de ça c'est honteux
honteux on critique pas les agriculteurs
en colère on essaie de comprendre
euh voilà alors elle a bien fait de
supprimer non mais voilà Sandrine là on
fait pas de politique et quand j'entends
effectivement les agriculteurs comme ça
c'est dramatique ce qu' V cy c'est leur
témoignage qui est essentiel parce que
ils vivent des drames euh Patrick euh
vous êtes agriculteur et membre de la
Coordination Rurale l'un de vos amis
s'est récemment suicidé à 49 ans face à
la pression et à la situation des
agriculteurs euh qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé avec votre ami Ben tout tout
d'abord je vous remercie de donner la
parole aux agriculteur et c'est nous qui
c'est nous qui vous remercions d'être là
non non ça c'est une chose cet ami bon
justement j'ai pas pu all l' terement en
fait parce qu' tout a été dit c'est
quelqu'un qui travaillait sur la ferme
de mon père donc j'ai connu et je ne
voyais plus beaucoup mais je connaissant
la personne son
dynamisme sa carure il était salarié
donc il s'est installé comme il croyait
à l'agriculture de salariés il s'est
installé donc je pense que c'est le plus
beau c'est un peu comme une personne qui
est salarié d'une entreprise et qui se
dit bah voilà je pense que je peux
mettre à mon compte et de finir comme ça
c'est dramatique bon après nous on a
tout le nord de la France a
énormément souffert des des conditions
climatique mais en fait c'est pas c'est
pas le c'est pas le premier c'est hélas
pas le
dernier aujour aujourd'hui en fait on a
cassé le système français agricole ouais
mais on l'a cassé petit à petit c'estàd
on l'a haché c'est dire on n pas dit
voilà c'est pas parce qu'il y a ça je
vais vous prendre deux exemples par
rapport par rapport à la personne parce
que j'avais sollicité j'avais déjà parlé
de ça il y a quasiment un an c'est avant
le salon l'année dernière aujourd'hui
pour pour contrôler un agriculteur il y
a des organismes et ça ça on a rien
compre vous savez ce qu'ils ont comme
arme ils ont un 357 Magnum ah oui pour
contrôler les agriculteurs s'ils
utilisent bien ou pas bien leur phyo ils
ont un 357 Magnum
c'estàd posez-vous la question c'està
dire non mais racontez-nous on comprend
pas en fait mais aujourd'hui les gens
qui viennent nous contrôler ont le droit
d'être armés non si ouais ouais alors
moi j'avais dit B quand la personne
n'est pas violente LESISS CZ de dans la
voiture vous voulez ce voulez savoir ce
qu'on m'a dit on m'a dit ouais mais si
on nous le pique dans la
voiture qu'est-ce que vous pourz
répondre à ça donc j'en ai parlé déjà il
y a un an on m'a dit oui c'est c'est
alors il paraît-il qu'il y a un un homme
d'État qui leur a permis de choisir leur
arme heureusement qu'il sont sont arrêté
au 357 alors je dis ça parce que on a
quelqu'un qui est décédé dans l'Oise
puisqu'il y a quelqu'un j'ai un confrère
dans l'Oise et l'année dernière il est
contrôlé il y avait une tâche de de
brûler à côté de son champ cette
personne donc a eu ses contrôleurs déjà
ça lui a fait un choc c'était pas lui
l'information et on lui a dit bah avec
ce que vous avez là ça va être 50 60
100000 € de pénalité lequel est rentré
chez lui s'est suicidé alors ça quand
vous alors on pourrait en donner des
tonnes d'exemples j'en ai tonnes mais
c'est pas là là le problème aujourd'hui
il y a ceux qui sont plus là il y a ceux
qui sont encore là et ceux qui sont
encore là aujourd'hui si on continue il
y a deux choses qui vont se passer faut
qu'on les préserve ceux qui son il y a
deux choses il y a il y a ça où les gens
comme je dis toujours ils le font de
leur côté j'ai un autre copain il l'a
fait il y a 2 ans suite au film qu'il a
vu et quelqu'un qui était bien qui avait
pas trop de souc financiers il a vu le
film et le lendemain il il a fait comme
dans le film c'estàd des choses que donc
c'est pour ça on en dit on donne des
mais quand ça vous touche tout près
c'est c'est épouvantable et moi je dis
aujourd'hui avec ce qui s'est passé là
je l'ai dit hier sur le sur le sur je
dirais sur les studios il faut prendre
des décisions rapides on a quelqu'un
aujourd'hui qui nous dit être rapide
aujourd'hui pour être clair et j'en ai
discuté avec Pascal qui est là qui vient
du sud et qui lui est vraiment dans le
créneau des gens et on a on a encore
échangé il m'a montré ce qui va se
passer cette nuit aujourd'hui il faut
être clair si le gouvernement il pense
qu'à l'usure à l'usure les gens vont
s'arrêter il fait un une grosse erreur
et j'ai dit parce que nous en tant que
responsable on essaie de calmer les gens
mais l'usure avec ce qui s'est passé là
le DC qui est dramatique avec des gens
je regarde votre émission c'est toujours
on dit c'est le dernier c'est le dernier
on va faire quelque chose dites-moi
c'est quelque chose qui est fait là ça
va partir en ville et ça va partir en
ville à cause du fait que les gens ne il
faut être clair on a des responsables
politiques quel qu'il soit il y a des
moments ils sont là pour prendre des
décisions qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par qu'on va
voir un trè un trème témoignage dans un
instant avec Stéphan moi j'ai envie de
savoir ce qu'on peut faire nous les
médias et des émissions comme la nôtre
qui voilà qui soit en direct tous les
soirs et on sait qu'on est quand même
assz écouté qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour alors je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire nous on est on est des gars de
la terre on est des gars qui bossont 60
70 80 90 heur par semaine comme disait
mon collègue on gagne pas le SMIC notre
job c'est pas d'aller faire la politique
nous le but c'est de vivre de ce qu'on
vous vend et de vivre pour nourrir les
les Français aujourd'hui je vais prendre
un seul exemple aujourd'hui et hier je
dit plus de 50 % de ce qui est fait en
de ce qui est consommé en France est
importé alors on a des politiques qui
nous dit mais nous on exporte alors je
vais vous dire c'est très simple la
planète en envie le produit français
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils achètent notre produit cher et
nous on importe des produits pas chers
exactement qu'on donne à manger à qui
aux gens qui ont des problèmes d'argent
exactement et on sait très bien que mal
se nourrir voilà c'est difficile d'être
centenaire c'est ça voilà Lee c'est pas
notre job aujourd'hui y a des Français
et on pense fort à eux qui sont obligés
aujourd'hui d'acheter des produits
beaucoup moins cher qui sont des
produits d'importation parce qu'
aujourd'hui et ben de mauvaise qualité
parfois mais ils sont obligés
aujourd'hui sinon leurs enfants ils
mangeent pas de légumes il mange pas de
fruits ils mangent pas de voilà il mange
pas et donc aujourd'hui ils sont obligés
donc le problème il est il est
incroyable quand vous dites c'est ça on
importe mais on exporte voilà on exporte
énormément aussi et on importe plus
aujourd'hui exactement c'est ça c'est le
problème et et si on pouvit n idé il y a
qu'une seule chose et on l'a déjà
demandé mais on comprend pas que ce soit
un frein un produit aujourd'hui qui est
fait en France qui est transformé en
France est un produit français avec une
belle cocarde aujourd'hui imporé un
produit qui est importé s'il est
travaillé en France il a la belle
cocarde donc vous vous faites le
consommateur se fait avoir ENF voir
c'est tout et pourquoi ça dure parce que
là voilà il y a juste qu'à dire ce qui
est produit en France et si c'est acheté
parce que là on va acheter du du du lait
en Nouvelle-Zélande c'est beaucoup mieux
que de, 50 de 10 % de prix en France on
va l'acheter à 20000 km et ben qu'on
nous dit c'est du lait de
Nouvelle-Zélande oui mais c'est pas
vraiment du lait parce que il est
travaillé en France non il vient de
Nouvelle-Zélande donc ça c'est à vous
dans votre job comme vous le faites bien
de dire aux politiques comment vous
positionnez quand vous allez le faire
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est
mathématique on sait que 10 ou 20 % de
de de vente en plus ou de prix en plus
les gens vivent bien parce que nous on
fait des chiffres d'affaires énormes et
il nous reste rien donc c'est pas
grand-chose et aujourd'hui comme je dis
la grande distribution l'industrielle et
c'est clair 60 % de marge en plus donc
c'est pas nous aujourd'hui la variable
d'ajustement che toujours le paysan